a woman moving to your place she like
this we have so much work to do no and
then she all she criticized everything
nasty you don't know how nasty you are
man
is that a blanket as your curtain
that's my blackout blanket you want to
darken this [__] or what where the
towels where's your towels
towel right there oh I see a towel
a [__] that's the towel
where's your pillowcase drawer
God the pillowcase on the pillow she's
like oh you have to change your sheets
every three days
[Laughter]
[Music]
girl it's three weeks on this side
flip that [__] is three weeks on that
side
and then there's two days you don't got
a pillowcase on the pillow cause you
wash it in the pillowcase